Speaker 1: Today, I am joined by James Cromwell,
actor, activist producer, whose new film Mondo
Hollywood Land, follows a politically confused
mushrooms dealer who traverses through Hollywood,
available now on Amazon Prime Video.
James, so great to have you on.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
So talk to us a little bit about this, this
film which you produced.
What?
What was the genesis of the idea here?
Speaker 6: The genesis of the idea was that
maybe it made him easier for him to sell the
film.
Speaker 1: So I love the honesty, I love it,
which matters a lot, which matter.
It's not a small issue.
Speaker 6: No, it is not.
That's not if you want your film to be seen.
Speaker 1: Can you talk a little bit about
the 60s era Mondo films that that this movie
is sort of an homage to and sort of what you
see is interesting about the genre?
Speaker 6: Well, I think if I if I have my
genres right, it's nouvelle vague.
It's Godard and Chabrol and Varda and Truffaut.
The new wave they called it.
I think of this film sort of as the boot to
surf, which is Godard's film only in color.
There were there are stories that Godard actually
knew that what he was doing was bad, but that
was the whole point.
So he was trying to look at the language of
film and develop a new syntax, a new way of
making films sort of the way Bertolt Brecht
does with what it's called very Freemans effect,
which is to distance an audience to keep them
aware that it is filmic, that it is a film
that is a fiction, it is a narrative.
It relates to something that is up for the
audience to create for themselves
Speaker 1: in hearing you talk in this way
about films.
I'm sort of I'm realizing, and I wonder if
you agree that this type of analysis of film
has become sorely lacking sort of in popular
culture in the United States at this point
in time.
Do you agree with that?
I mean, it seems to me that the richness of
the discussion of film in this style is not
what it once was in popular society.
Speaker 6: Certainly in America.
Cut in America film is considered a product.
A studio has a certain studio works, is owned
by a corporation.
That corporation has obligations to its shareholders
to produce the profit they produce.
This thing called a film cinema.
They show the cinema and they try to reach
as broad an audience as possible, so they
either play down to that audience or through
the media that they also control.
They create reviews that make the thing seem
as vacuous as possible.
So it's not send anybody before they they're
sitting in the seats watching it.
Speaker 1: So there's two layers.
In other words, the film is created in a certain
way.
But the discussion of that film and its promotion
could still be more substantive.
But even that in order to make the film appealing,
is is kept relatively superficial.
So you really have two layers of this that
you're fighting against.
Speaker 6: Yeah, if you think of a film like
Joker and you think, well, they're going to
take out, they're going to take that film
seriously.
You know, some people, which I'm really glad
were offended by that film, but there's a
lot to unpack in that film.
There's a lot of discussions about who we
are, where we are, what we're doing.
Are we insane who runs the show?
What can we do as individuals to oppose it?
What is the cost of living in a dysfunctional
society when your entire mental structure
is, is come together from falsehood?
Mm-Hmm.
Speaker 1: I remember watching an interview
with Charlie Rose, interviewed the late David
Foster Wallace, and they were just chatting
about different things.
And Charlie Rose asks David Foster Wallace
his opinion about the English Patient.
And after sort of in that that David Foster
Wallace sense of saying, You really care.
What I think about the English Patient is
that you are you really asking me that?
He says.
I think it's a beautifully filmed commercial
Hollywood endeavor that was sort of like his
top line analysis that fundamentally it's
still it looks nice, but it's a profit driven
Hollywood endeavor is your top line analysis
of a film similar where you're looking at
what was the point of the production here?
Was it an independent project?
Was it a profit driven project, Hollywood,
et cetera?
Speaker 6: That that enters into my thinking
also the way that certain.
What would I call them, not metaphors, but
when they use contemporary situations, circumstances,
events that really happened or real people
exploitative Lee without examining what they're
doing, they just use it because it it gives
a patina of reality of of pertinence.
And I think it's a great mistake.
People do that with the with the Holocaust.
They do that with the Nazis.
They do that in a variety of ways.
The politics are always what it comes down
to is it's basically a boy meets girl, boy
loses girl, boy gets girl.
Hmm.
So a film like Syriana, which has many, many,
many, many, many, many layers?
Yeah, and is a provocative if you think about
it gets short shrift because they know the
powers that be.
Is that an audience is not going to be able
to analyze that film from an understanding
of what the reality is.
So they'll miss half the film and say, What
was that all for?
I don't understand.
I like George Clooney.
So funny.
Why can't he do?
And do you think, Well, that's that's a waste.
Speaker 1: It's so interesting that that you
mentioned that movie, because that's one that
I've thought about in this context where when
you look at the analysis and the discussion
of it, it it's it's talking about 20 or 30
percent of the film.
And like you're pointing out, there's so much
substance there that seems to be above the
radar in a sense or below.
I don't know.
Yeah, I agree.
When it comes to you mentioned the Holocaust,
for example, as one topic, sometimes that's
touched in certain ways and not others.
I just finished up reading the book Technopolis
by the critic Neil Postman, where he talks
about in the education context in the United
States, and this book was written in 1992,
but still relevant.
There's often agreement about what are valuable
topics in school, and the Holocaust is one
that is considered.
We teach about the Holocaust, we teach about
slavery, et cetera.
Similarly, in literature, there are often
books or authors where there's a sort of consensus
like it's important that students read this,
but less commonly, is there really thought
given to what is it that we want people to
learn?
And then how should they use this in their
lives going forward?
Like, what's the point?
What do we want people to take away from learning
about the Holocaust or whatever the case may
be?
Is that applicable to film as well when some
of these events or ideas are used just to
make a movie a movie?
Excuse me?
Speaker 6: Oh, yes, I think it is.
I did a film called the Panama Papers, I think
it was called the papers and.
It was interesting because the Panama Panama
Papers revelations it seemed to exclude every
American.
There was no American mentioned and there's
no real connection to and there was an event
in America.
But it was the it wasn't central to what the
story was about, which was how this catastrophe
occurred.
And I know I'm noticing the same things in
this new revelation the Pandora papers that
it's all about Kenyatta of Kenya and somebody
in Czechoslovakia and and all these people.
Then they say, and celebrities and I don't
know what the that consortium of independent
journalists thought was happening with people
who have a great deal of money because that's
what they do.
They make very clear that there's no there's
no criminality involved, but at the same time,
they don't show you the whole story, which
is two of our states, Delaware and South Dakota
are probably two of the biggest offshore deposits
of people's money that there are.
Yeah, so.
So in other words, in almost any time, your
film is a very simple medium.
If you overlay it with a lot of fact, if there's
a lot of levels to understanding, it's very
hard to keep an eye on because an audience
is only interested not only in the narrative,
but seeing themselves in the character so
that they can experience the thing that the
things that the character does.
And they play the sort of game isolated by
themselves.
Whereas you get a film like the Battle of
Algiers, which I saw back in the 60s in a
movie house in New York, and there were Black
Panthers up in the front row, right right
in front of me.
And of course, they understood every nuance
of that film because they'd seen it in their
community.
But I.
A nice white boy sitting behind him.
I'm looking at this film.
It's revelatory, but I know nothing about
how the police, how the state operates in
a ghetto to suppress the aspirations of the
people.
Right.
Speaker 1: A couple things I wanted to ask
about.
Maybe related to this you've been arrested
several times doing activism.
It's typically like trespassing, basic civil
disobedience.
Does that have any long term impact in any
kind of legal sense?
Do those arrests matter because they're not,
they don't rise to the level interestingly
enough of where you start falling, subject
to like a three strikes and you're out sort
of thing.
Did it have any impact at all on you?
Speaker 6: Well, actually it does in Texas.
The one I have in Texas, I'm still on probation,
which means that I cannot.
I get arrested in any state for breaking any
law.
And you know, if I had a larger a career,
I suppose that I would be like some wonderful
people in Hollywood who actually do do really
great work.
I'm not sure that Sean Penn gets the opportunities
to do the work now that he did before because
of the work that he did in Haiti and the enemies
that he made in Haiti, namely the Clinton
Foundation and and the United Nations, and
what he saw and how he reacted to it and how
he spoke about it.
So I don't know.
My activism, I don't think raises to that
rises to that level.
But people do notice and it is a valid ticket.
It is a technique of civil disobedience breaking
the law in order to bring attention to the
law to two crimes that are being committed
inside of the law.
And there would be ramifications to my career.
There may be, but I can't stop it.
I have to continue doing what I'm doing.
No doubt.
Speaker 1: No doubt.
You were a Bernie supporter, are you?
What's your sense so far of Joe Biden's presidency?
Speaker 6: How many Haitians, as you said,
back home?
What's he doing at the border?
Hmm.
What's it what?
Listen, this is the same with Obama.
Obama had both have both houses of Congress.
He had the presidency.
He did absolutely squat.
I don't think much changes between that administration
and what it managed to accomplish since it
until it got into the sort of stalemate that's
going to exist in 2022, when the Republicans
take back the House.
We're going to be in the same bloody position.
If the change as as.
Turnberry says and the other young buyer and
environmentalists say is not going to come
from the blah blah blah of politicians, it's
going to come from the street.
It's kind of come from the demands of people,
and I think I think that will happen.
Speaker 1: So you don't think too highly so
far of what of what Joe Biden has done clearly?
Do you do you distinguish between is there
a consequence to the fact that it's Joe Biden
and not another four years of Trump?
Speaker 6: It's not another four years of
Trump, but we are in the sixties rush to say,
yeah, but it's so much is so much like it
under the surface when you watch the policies,
what's happening around the world?
When are we going to start?
Well, it looks like we're trying to start
a war with China.
But what's going to happen around the world
to this war state that we have created to
satisfy the needs of the military industrial
complex?
We need those wars, we need those bases.
I just watched a film on the F-35, the F-35,
the development.
The F-35 is going to cost, what, over one
trillion dollars between one and $1.7 billion.
They're they're being sold at $180 million
apiece.
What what are we doing as we head towards
the precipice of environmental destruction?
What are we doing supporting this industry,
those industries and the extraction industries?
So he's open.
He just opened up a whole new drilling thing
off the coast of off the West Coast after
they had that oil spill caused by a ship dragging
its anchor and puncturing a pipe.
Yeah, there's no way to have this system,
and I buy that this system, I mean capitalism
and have a democratic solution to the problems
that all the problems that dealers the environment,
racism, sexism, the across the lot.
Nothing is going to change as long as people
put profit ahead of people.
Speaker 1: Do you see these systems in places
like Denmark, Norway and Sweden as sufficiently
different?
Or is that not enough?
Speaker 6: No, I think it's sufficiently different.
It's not a no.
It's not enough.
It needs to be reexamined.
However, if we had the system of the Scandinavian
countries, we could at least have a dialog
about what's happening in this country, right?
What's happening to the people who feel so
disaffected that they attacked the Congress
of the United States violently to achieve
what?
They their lives were not appreciably made
better by that man's presidency.
So what are they thinking?
Are they thinking or are they being led by
an Australian named Murdoch to not be able
to distinguish the truth from falsehood when
it's right in their faces and it's them?
Yeah.
Is this the worst?
Speaker 1: He's up there for sure.
He is up there for sure, yeah.
We've been speaking with actor and activist
James Cromwell.
The new film is Mondo Hollywood Land.
James, I so appreciate being able to speak
with you.
The film is now available on Amazon Prime
Video, and we're linking to it.
Really a pleasure speaking with you today.
Speaker 6: Likewise, enjoy the film.
It's really a wonderful film.
See it!